how's it going everybody welcome to our
ask a career coach my name is Martin
McGovern and we are just getting started
it's about two o'clock so we're gonna
give it a few minutes for people to join
and again our topic for today is does a
LinkedIn profile replace a personal
portfolio website it's gonna be a fun
question we're gonna dig into it and
then we're gonna open it up to all the
questions that you have on your mind so
if you've got friends who are job
searching right now ping them and tell
them to come join if you have questions
put them in the chat and one thing I'd
like to know is where in the world are
you joining us from I'm in Chicago right
now and would just love to just hear how
how many people from all different parts
of the globe well we got in the call
today thanks for joining
just hold on for a minute or two as we
allow people to join the chat thank you
we got Utah we got San Diego
we got south south suburbs of Chicago
how's it goin
neighbors Ann Arbor Michigan Egypt
all right thank you
for submitting your questions we're
gonna be collecting all the questions we
have Karen in the chat she's gonna be
passing them on to me and I'll be
digging into each one as they come
through so please please please put your
questions in the chat and we'll be
getting to them shortly
emeritus a Lawrence Kansas
Guatemala Algeria Brazil Chile India
somewhere where the snow is it's 30
degrees Fahrenheit I guess and the snow
is it almost looks like it says the snow
is 30 feet India and Nigeria West
Virginia Morocco Algeria France Brazil
Florida Venezuela India is amazing yes
it is being recorded thank you for your
question Ivan so you'll be able to come
back and watch this anytime you want
well I also chop it up and share it in
bits in question by question that is
going to be slowly rolled out over time
so if you are curious feel free to
connect with me on LinkedIn I'll be
sharing those individual clips clips out
as well we got Paraguay Sudan one thing
to call out as we get into our chat
today my background is in marketing and
career development so I have a lot of
great insights into the job search how
to promote yourself how to get seen how
to connect with people build
relationships interview all that good
stuff but when it comes to the hyper
technical questions about coding that is
where my knowledge and my expertise you
know ends and so if you do have
technical questions feel free to ask
them and bring them to the slack channel
of the alumni slack channel where we can
actually bring it you know bring you
some real good advice from folks who are
doing that work
I can only give you broad strokes but
they can give you the real answers so
it's great that you have those questions
let Karen know she'll point you in the
right place - to share those out and get
some feedback oh thank you so much thank
you for being a fan
Niraj I really appreciate you joining us
today it's awesome we got Egypt san
diego looks like we're about four
minutes so we're about to get started
just one more minute Kenya oh man we got
everyone from all over the world here
today I'm loving it alright we are about
five minutes in so we're gonna get
started with our first topic and our
first topic today is the question does a
LinkedIn per profile does a LinkedIn
profile replace a personal portfolio
website now this is a really interesting
question and we just released a video
this morning on LinkedIn about it and
there's a number of different things
that you want to think about as you are
analyzing your LinkedIn your personal
website and all the other profiles that
you have out on the internet this is
more than question about LinkedIn versus
a profile it's a question about your
online presence your online brand and
what it is that you're trying to
showcase to the world so these companies
that are googling you can get the right
information right all right so to simply
answer the question does a LinkedIn
profile replace your personal portfolio
website the answer is you know
unfortunately I know you all want me to
say yes so that there's less work to be
done but the truth of the matter is your
online presence is a combination of many
different sources your github your
LinkedIn your personal website and other
areas on the web Twitter LinkedIn or
Twitter Instagram different things like
that now the reason that it doesn't
replace it is because each serves a
different purpose
when
you're thinking about your LinkedIn
profile what is it really
well it's actually a number of different
things your LinkedIn profile is a
supercharged or you know amped up
version of your resume it takes what you
have to try and force in to one page and
allows you some more breathing room to
share more examples more bullet points
more jobs all the different stuff it's
really a chronicle of everything you've
accomplished within your career
volunteer work personal projects
everything and it's all so much better
than a resume and by the way you do need
a resume as well it does not replace the
resume what's what makes it so much
better than a resume is you can include
media in each position so you can link
to presentations you've done projects
you've worked on all sorts of different
things and you can also amp it up with
different keywords that you want to be
known for because recruiters are going
to be finding you based on the keywords
that they type in they're going to be
typing and you know programmer with you
know C++ HTML whatever the thing is and
so it's not only a great place to
showcase your work like a resume is but
you know much more developed it's also a
place to be found because that's where
the majority of companies and recruiters
are and they are using it as a tool as a
research tool to find candidates now the
great thing about it is the research
tool works both ways so not only can you
be found if you have a robust profile
but you can use the same search tools to
find people to network with companies to
work for and jobs to to seek out so it's
a really wonderful tool for both
showcasing as well as researching and
connecting more importantly with people
who can help you in your career people
who you want to you know work for
someday and all these different things
follow companies research companies all
that great stuff but LinkedIn falls
short in the visual design because it
needs to be ubiquitous and because it
needs to be able to hold so much data
and information and it's really more of
a research tool than a showcase all
those media links that I talked about
that you can put in there are tiny
little boxes and a lot of them are
hidden
and a lot of people won't click on them
so if you are only using LinkedIn and
all of your projects are in these tiny
little boxes hard to find hard to scroll
hard to see then people aren't going to
be able to get to the thing that you
want them to see the most it might get
lost in the shuffle so what we want to
do is create a personal website what the
great thing about a personal website
personal portfolio is that there's a
large variety of ways you can do it you
can have one page site a blog site a
portfolio site as was mentioned in the
question you can really be creative and
you can do a lot of different things
and unlike LinkedIn which you have no
control over the design you can actually
control every element of how your
personal website looks so it's an
extremely important thing to own in your
not just your job search but in your
life own your presence on the Internet
and so what companies can do is they can
go to that profile and see a little bit
more about your personality see the
projects that you want to highlight see
any articles you've written or things
you've wanted to share or bring to the
the top of the pile
you know everything is chronological
LinkedIn but you can just put your best
stuff at the top on your personal
website so if you take a look at my
website versus my LinkedIn they are they
serve two completely different purposes
one is just a collection of all these
videos literally in a grid and the other
one is all of my past work history laid
out very easy for people to see the
other thing that you want to keep in
mind when it comes to any sort of social
web page any sort of online profile is
that who knows what's gonna happen with
LinkedIn in the next thirty years it
could go the way of MySpace you know it
could be a place that no one goes to I
don't think that's gonna happen but
you'd never really know so you never
want to hang your hat on any one
platform you know Instagram could easily
become MySpace Facebook is already kind
of turning into MySpace snapchat is
uncertain of where that's going to end
up so you want to diversify your online
presence the same way you would
diversify you know an investment plan
you want to have
things that you own and you control no
one can really take your website away
from you ever and you are always in
control of how it looks the algorithm
won't change on it the the design won't
suddenly change on it if you're on
YouTube but you know a lot of youtubers
complain that like things get
demonetised like there's all sorts of
things outside of your control in these
platforms that you join alright so
that's a couple of reasons why you want
to use one over the other but another
thing to keep in mind and this was in
the video this morning that was released
is the idea around the job search of do
I need to do this do I really need to
network do I really need to build a
website do I really need to be
practicing my development skills on the
side do I have to do all these things
and it's an interesting question that
comes up because I understand the
frustration I understand when you go to
start your job search you're told that
you need to create like 8 million
different profiles you need an indie
profile and a Glassdoor profile and a
LinkedIn profile and a personal website
and a github profile and it just goes on
and on and on right there's just no end
to the number of profiles that you need
to create now of course you want to be
smart you don't you don't have to do
everything you need to prioritize you
don't need a you know to be active on
LinkedIn Twitter there's maybe eight or
five to eight places that you should be
active on and even then you should
prioritize how active you are on each
place like I'm personally very active on
Linkedin not so active on Twitter barely
active on Instagram right that might
change in the future but that's the
current set up but the key thing that I
want to take away from this discussion
is the mentality of I don't want to do
that I don't want to I just I just want
to apply to jobs through indeed or I
just want to apply to jobs through
LinkedIn why won't that just work why
isn't that enough and the truth of the
matter is that we live in a very
competitive world so of course that's
not gonna be enough there's lots of
people and if you're doing the bare
minimum thing you're gonna get the bare
minimum or let's say if you do the
average thing you're gonna get the
average results and the average results
are very few responses
from online job boards and so what we
want to do is instead of this yesBut
mindset it's like yes I know but I don't
want to do that I don't want to put the
time in we need to flip it to a yes and
mindset or yeah and so in the video we
shared this morning this is a concept
from the world of improv where anytime
someone throws out a suggestion you have
two ways you can respond to it the first
one is saying no but that's not right
and the second way is to say yes and
here's how I'm gonna do it or here's how
I'll respond it's about accepting the
fact of the world and then building on
it so all right you need to have a
personal website yes and I'm going to
make it look like this or yes and I'm
going to share this information there or
yes and I can't wait to put showcase my
projects things like that so try and
adopt this yes and mindset go watch that
video it's up on LinkedIn and just
really embrace it because it's going to
be something that all right she's not
unlike the know beyond YouTube later
today so keep an eye on our YouTube
channel
and so just keep that in mind cuz it's
really gonna be helpful in everything
you do in your career when someone says
you should network instead of saying no
but I'm not ready into network you
should say yes and I'm gonna reach out
to someone I know first to start
practicing all right so that's the
mindset that I want us to get into as we
approach the job search and now we're
gonna dig into the rest of your
questions here today
[Music]
all right our first question is from
Rachel how do I start a new job after a
two-year break now this is a big
question and the first thing that I need
to know in response is what were you
doing over that two-year period were you
taking care of your family were you you
know out for some other reasons what
were the reasons because that's gonna
shape the way in which you develop your
plan and your story to get back into the
game but in general when it comes to
starting a new job after a two-year
break the first thing you're gonna need
to do is define exactly what it is you
want to do you probably are sitting
there with lots of ideas a lot of things
that went through your mind over the
past two years oh I could do that I
could do this I could do I could live
here I could live there there's a
million options right there's this
concept called analysis paralysis or
choice paralysis where the more
open-ended our options are
the harder it is to make a decision and
we made a video about this it's you know
you're walking down the toothpaste aisle
and you're like do I need tartar control
but I need whitening do I need gel do I
need pace do I need sparkles do I need a
spongebob there's so many different
things that you've got to consider and
if you really tried to break it all down
it's just gonna be too crazy so what you
need to do is simplify your options the
first thing I would suggest you do is
say this is where I'm going to live I
see all the time job searches where I'm
applying in Texas I'm applying in
California I'm applying in Alaska I'm
applying in it's like whoa below you you
got a narrow down before you start
sending out all these applications
because it's just too crazy your brain
is too scattered when you have too many
options in front of you and when you
talk to people they're gonna say well
what are you looking for and if you just
say I'm looking for any job in any
industry anywhere in the world no one
can help you but if you say something
specific like I'm looking for a
programming internship that works with a
certain program in the automobile
industry in this state let's say Detroit
or something
right that is a very specific thing that
I can go look at my network find someone
and connect you so number one be very
specific on where you want to be number
two be very specific on what industry
you want to be in so it could be health
and beauty it could be autumn of
automotive it could be banking it could
be education Google LinkedIn industry
codes and it'll give you a great list to
sort of break this down so you can
choose a couple and then you want to be
very specific about your job title now
different companies have the same job
title but when you actually get in there
it's a completely different role and
other companies have completely
different job titles but it's the same
role you got it to a little bit of
networking in order to figure out if
this role that you think you want the
one that you think you want your head
actually aligns to what the reality of
the role is so you're gonna pick maybe
two or three of your favorite job titles
prioritize them and then go meet people
who do those jobs in order to confirm
your initial assumptions or deny your
initial assumptions so that would be
where I start be very clear on your
location
be very clear on your industry be very
clear on your job title and then use
that information to go network with the
right people specifically people who
live in that location work in that
industry and have that job title and if
you do that you'll be moving in the
right direction to get back on your feet
and then the two-year break the way you
just talked about that is say here's
what I did here's what I learned here's
what I was working on or just explain
the situation and say that so that's
what I've been doing the past two years
what I'm currently working on is
learning XY and Z and I'm really excited
to apply it to this location this
industry this job and you just move
forward it spend less time looking back
but don't ignore it just address it and
just talk about the future of what you
want to do
all right our next question how to use
LinkedIn to find a job in the field of
data science and machine learning great
question oh sorry I gotta say the name
before I say the question Hamzah how do
I use LinkedIn to find a job in the
field of data science and machine
learning awesome question so when it
comes to finding a job in any industry
but data science machine learning the
first thing I'd ask you to do is say
well which one do you want to focus on
again back to the focus the more focus
that we have the better so data science
and machine learning which one are you
how would you prioritize the two then
say what companies do I respect that are
working in this area and you might not
know what the companies are so go to the
LinkedIn people search if you look at
the search bar at LinkedIn it gives you
three options of how to search the first
one is jobs which is where we all start
the second one is people and the third
one is content now you can use content
as well if you click on the hashtag for
machine learning what's really
interesting about that if you click on
that hashtag it'll bring up all the
companies that are sharing any sort of
posts about machine learning and you
might find a lot of small companies a
lot of you know we all go after the big
names but that's not the big names are
hard to get into because everyone wants
to be at the big name if you go find
some small name companies you can get a
job much much faster because the
competition is lower so what you can do
is you can click on that hashtag it'll
pull up all the posts about machine
learning and you can just start
scrolling through and saying and this
could be in the content search so the
search bar for content you start saying
alright this company shared a post about
machine learning are they a machine
learning company click through to the
company profile take a look at the jobs
they have open take a look at the
employee list and say oh they do have
some machine learning data signs people
on staff I'm going to reach out to those
people connected them see if there's any
you know opportunities to help out and
work there so that
one way to use hashtags in order to
explore LinkedIn and find opportunities
and then the other way is to just go
straight to the the people search and
type in machine learning as the job
title again the location in the industry
that you want to be in and it'll bring
up a list of probably you know something
between 500 and a thousand people and
you can go down the list and say this
person works at that company as a
machine learning engineer I'm now I know
that that company hires for machine
learning that if they've hired for
machine learning before there's a good
chance they're gonna hire for machine
learning again so I'm gonna follow that
company I'm gonna reach out to that
person I'm gonna start building a
relationship so that the next time a job
opening happens in in that company for
machine learning you can just reach out
to that person say hey we chatted a few
months back I really appreciate you
sharing all that information I saw this
opening come up would you be willing to
pass along my resume and that's how you
really use LinkedIn to do research to
network and to pursue these jobs so
that's what again that's why LinkedIn is
such a wonderful place because it kind
of brings it all together if you just
had your personal website you wouldn't
be able to do all this stuff on the
right people aren't coming to your
personal website very much but LinkedIn
has all those tools so utilize them
the next question here comes from Shakti
how can I become a successful web
developer the first thing I'll say in
response this question is I am NOT a web
developer so knowing how to you know day
to day become a successful web developer
isn't going to be the thing that I'm
going to be able to comment on that's
gonna be something that you're gonna
want to reach out to people who you
think are already successful web
developers and ask them how did they
become as successful as they are awesome
conversation starter complimentary
toward them and a good networking
connection for you so I would say the
first thing you want to do in order to
become a successful web developer is to
reach out to successful web developers
and try and surround yourself with
people who are already successful in
that field this is gonna be something
that you're gonna feel intimidated by
because you don't feel successful yet
but you got to challenge yourself to
reach out to the people that are leading
in the field and so you are the average
of the five people that you spend the
most time with try and surround yourself
with people who you think either are
successful or are going to be successful
look around to the people that you know
who are doing what you do but are
dedicated to it are excited about it
really enjoy talking about it love
learning about it those are the people
that will help bring you to the next
level and bring you to the next level
and bring you to the next level
throughout your career if you if you
don't have anyone around you that is
interested in what you're interested in
it's hard to really dedicate your time
to it you feel kind of isolated you
start to wonder if this was the right
choice but if you have a good network of
people even people at your level that's
a wonderful way to continue to sort of
set yourself up for success over a
lifetime another thing to keep in mind
is to pay it back join some professional
organizations mentor people who are
below you as you're moving up so it's
not just about you getting value you
know from the people higher than you
it's about giving back to the people who
are coming up behind you and I think if
you really try and provide value in both
door
actions you're going to really but set
yourself up for a great career as a web
developer and then just really basically
do it every day
you know if this is what you really
enjoy if this is what you're interested
in and you want to be great at it if you
want to be successful at it there really
shouldn't be a time that you you know
want to stop I mean you'll want to stop
we all we all get tired we all burn out
we all feel demotivated don't worry
about that stuff but when you're
thinking about what should I do next
go read more books go build more
projects go collaborate with more people
make it fun make it interesting make it
something that apply it to a bigger
issue that you care about maybe if you
want to be a web developer and you also
really care about humanitarian efforts
or you also really care about food waste
or you also really care about other
things volunteer for organizations where
you can practice your skill set and also
help the cause you care about these are
things that really help keep you engaged
and focused and growing over over time
[Music]
should I wait for my interview prep
sorry Anita should I wait for my
interview preparation to finish before
applying for jobs
I finished the front end nano degree two
months back should I wait for my
interview preparation to finish before
applying for jobs I think what I want to
dig into on this question is the idea of
waiting why are we waiting to do
anything we're waiting out of insecurity
we're waiting out of fear we're waiting
because we don't feel ready we're
waiting because we don't want to look
stupid I hear this all the time I'm
gonna wait to reach out to that person
until I know more or I'm going to wait
to apply for that job until I've taken
this other course while it might be true
that you're not ready for that role yet
I think what's more important than being
ready is building a skillset of action
every time you wait to do something you
ingrained in your brain that waiting is
a is the proper course of action and
what's going to end up happening is if
you keep doing that during the job
search it's going to carry over into the
job and what's gonna happen is you're
going to be assigned a project and
you're not gonna feel ready for it and
you're gonna procrastinate it because
your baseline is to wait not to ask
questions not to go do something but to
wait and so we want to really challenge
ourselves anytime that our brain starts
saying wait wait wait wait wait we want
to say well why am I actually waiting
what is the harm that's gonna happen
from taking action so if someone says I
want to wait to network until I know
more because I don't want to feel stupid
well you could wait the rest of your
life
when will you ever get to a point where
you know everything it just won't happen
because the technology will keep
changing and then the other thing you
have to realize is the other person
you're talking to doesn't know
everything
so what we are foundationally thinking
what what our brain is telling us is
that we need to be a certain way before
we can do something when
the truth of the matter is we just have
to change our perspective on it we need
to move from I need to be perfect I need
to be knowledgeable to I already am
curious and I am learning this is
another step in my learning process is
to learn how to reach out to people
learn how to have conversations about
things I don't know all the answers to
and learn how to ask good questions in
order to continue learning and growing
you can't learn and grow if you're not
networking and meeting people and
talking about things so when it comes to
waiting for your interview prep to
finish my answer would be don't wait
just go do stuff and as you're doing
stuff you'll fail at a bunch of it and
then get better at doing that thing
right you'll get feedback yeah just go
start applying if there's like certain
jobs that you really really want to
apply to I think it's fine to send to
wait till your third application that
you send out to send it to the one you
really want so you can kind of brush off
the cobwebs but don't wait till it like
a month or two later just like get a
couple down to companies you don't care
about and then go after the bigger fish
so don't wait just do Thank You Anita
all right again I'm gonna apologize
because I'm not great at names but I
believe this pronounced Jah Jah has a
question how do you how does github play
a role in building our profile I want to
again caveat this with I'm not a
developer so I don't use github however
from the conversations that I've had and
the people that I've chatted with and
and the knowledge that I've sort of
gleaned from all these interactions with
you all get hub's role is to do a couple
of things one I believe you can use it
to connect with other people and
collaborate on projects and then number
two it shows that you're constantly
learning from an outside perspective it
shows that you're constantly learning
and growing over time the most important
thing for from an outsider looking in
let's say I'm a hiring manager
I go to your LinkedIn profile you're get
I go to your github profile and I look
at that square of activity all those
green shaded dots squares the grid right
that green shaded grid if your grid is
solid and like you are active every day
and you are updating every day and you
are doing things showing that you're
learning showing that you're growing
showing that you're building that's
gonna look really really good if I go to
your github and there's like three or
four dots and a bunch of white space
it's gonna show me that you're not
really dedicated that you're probably
not learning and you're probably not
growing during this time of your job
search and I'm gonna start asking why
why did you stop and you know there's a
million reasons to stop but the people
that I see who are super active and have
very heavily green grids are also the
people that are super active in their
job search and applying to lots of
companies and networking a bunch and
things like that because they know it's
important to be consistent and they know
it's important to be updating things
every day and not waiting a week to take
action on stuff so I think in building
your online presence it's one element in
a larger group of elements but it's one
that you want to keep consistent and you
want to show growth because that's going
to be something that companies value
when they come and check out your gap
thank you so much for your question
our next
Musab if I enrolled in a if I enrolled
in the university oh here we go alright
so if I enrolled in a university in the
past and did not complete my bachelor
degree
do I need to include that in my LinkedIn
profile this is a great question this is
one that's definitely up for debate I
think it depends on a number of factors
the first thing is how long were you in
the university it was its what and and
also how much and also how much work
history do you have if all you have is
your University work it's debatable of
whether or not you should include it
because if you have nothing else to sort
of fill out the gaps it might just be a
glaring hole in let's say you were there
for two three years they're gonna say
well what were you doing in that time in
their head they're not gonna actually
ask you that but in their head they'll
be like well what happened in this gap
here right that's becoming more and more
acceptable to have gaps but I do think
that you know it's something that you
might want to sit down and think about
and maybe address if needed however when
it comes to you know your your
educational background if if you don't
feel comfortable talking about it in an
interviewer with people then it's maybe
not something you want to include right
away but I would encourage you to feel
good about talking about it so let's say
the reason that you didn't finish your
bachelor degree is because you went to a
boot camp or you started a job or you
know you changed interests or maybe the
financials didn't work out there's a lot
of reasons that are acceptable to talk
about and then just say because I didn't
have to I didn't get to finish here's
what I've done instead of gone to
Udacity I've learned these other things
I've worked on these projects and you
just sort of shift the conversation into
what you do want to talk about so I
would say in the past you know if you
haven't if you have these things if you
don't know how to talk about it don't
include it if you do know how to talk
about it even though it might not look
great on paper I would say it might be
something that's okay to include but try
and hit us up in the chat
or email me or hit me up on LinkedIn and
we can maybe fill out some of the gaps
there so that you can feel comfortable
with whatever decision you make here
because I don't think it's as a cut and
dry as a yes or no but thank you so much
for your question all right our next
question comes from Ann cush how can I
reach potential recruiters through a
LinkedIn search this is a great question
do recruiters want you to reach out to
them I'm not sure it seems to me from
the experience that I've had in the
stories I've heard recruiters it's hard
word to say sometimes recruiters want to
reach out to you they don't necessarily
want you reaching out to them they have
their search queries and they're going
through and they are reaching out to
dozens hundreds of people trying to find
the right person for the job so if you
reach out to them it could be beneficial
you might have some good conversations
but they have so many people that
they're looking at and again at the end
of the day or not again but at the end
of the day the recruiters job is not to
get you a job the recruiters job is to
help the company find the best candidate
so they don't work for you so if you're
asking them to do the job search for you
if you're reaching out trying to
outsource the work so you don't have to
do it that's not going to be fun for
them they're not gonna want to do your
job search for you they want to find
good candidates that are a no-brainer so
they look for things like your education
history did you go to a big-name college
your work history did you work at Google
did you work at Facebook you know those
are the things that make it easy to sell
someone but if you do reach out to them
you need to think about it from their
perspective
you need to show them give them a good
story as to why you'd be a candidate be
specific don't just say hey I'm Martin
and I need a job and your recruiter give
me a job it's just not gonna work that
way so instead of reaching out to
potential recruiters on LinkedIn I would
recommend reaching out to people who
actually work at the company
two people have the job title that you
want reach out to people who work in the
marketing team reach out to people that
do all sorts of different jobs so that
when you actually get to an interview
you can talk about the company as a well
versed knowledgeable person and those
contacts that you'll make and the
referral like if you can get someone to
give you an internal referral that beats
a recruiter any day so I would highly
recommend instead of spending your time
on recruiters who have lots and lots of
people vying for their attention try and
reach out to some people who maybe
aren't getting a lot of attention the
people who just have the job title that
you want to have they're not on the
hiring team but they know the people on
the hiring team potentially so that's a
really good place to start and thank you
so much for your question
[Music]
Jamal I love this question thank you so
much for sharing it what kind of posts
should we post on LinkedIn
great question okay so I was talking
about this with someone yesterday and
when it comes to what to share online
this is there's a few things I want to
talk about the first one is why should
you share anything the reason you want
to share things online is because every
time you share something or comment on
something or like something your name
pops up on someone else's screen what
that means is like look around the world
I think we see something like 2,000
advertisements a day pop-ups banner ads
billboards bus ads TV ads Instagram ads
everything is everywhere right Amazon is
amazing at this you you search something
on Amazon it will show up a hundred
times on a hundred different devices to
the point where you're like fine I'll
buy it just to get this to go away right
and so what we want to do what we want
to think about as we're going out there
sorry the gain is a little high on my
microphone we'll see if I can turns on
bit yeah I think it's that way
all right so what we want to think about
well we want to think about as we're
posting as we're sharing stuff is what
do we want to pop up on someone else's
screen with do we want to be you know
sharing things about the food we bake or
like oh I baked a cake yesterday could
be something you want to be known for do
you want to talk about the books you're
reading also something interesting do
you want to talk about the projects
you're building also interesting
articles you're reading also interesting
the more related your posts are to what
you want out of out of each of these
profiles the better it will be so let's
get into some specifics here so if last
night I was chatting with someone and he
was asked me what to post on LinkedIn he
had this post about minimalism that he
really wanted to put up and so I you
know we were just talking about it and
I'm like look if I posted videos about
baking would you have come up to me at
this networking event and talk to me
about careers you would have come up and
talked to me about baking right so if he
posts things about minimalism while it's
interesting it's not exploring his
expertise in programming which is what
he wanted to get a job in so what we
talked about we went back and forth for
a little bit and we came to the idea of
what about minimalism in programming how
to simplify websites how to simplify
code how to simplify the process of
building a project you know these you
can take your minimalist personality
identity interest and apply it to what
you're interested to your career
interests and that will be a unique
perspective that people might want to
share comment on and things like that so
when you're thinking about what to share
try to make it relevant to the things
that you want people to know about you
and if you're on LinkedIn specifically
make it about your work yeah I'm not
gonna be sharing any any videos of me
cooking number one
because I'm a terrible cook but number
two because it's just not relevant to
what you need and that's the other thing
to keep in mind what do other people
care about can you um
can you share information that isn't
just talking about yourself and how
great you are but also solving people's
problems
the videos that we share on LinkedIn if
it was just me talking about how great
my career is number one I mean my career
has ups and downs just like everyone
else
so it's not authentic but number two
it's not interesting to people we at
least in my own opinion I try to share
things that that help people right and
so maybe you can put that twist maybe
you don't have things that you know how
to help people with yet then just share
your projects share things that you're
interested in maybe just think what
would someone be interested in clicking
on and find an article about it and
share it so number one the reason that
you share the reason that you post and
the reason you like and comment and all
that other stuff aside from it just
being you know fun for some people a lot
of people are lurkers and they don't
they don't want to comment but it brings
you to the top of mind for people
congratulate people on their raises
comment like when people post stuff they
love it when people comment and like so
every it's almost like up voting on
reddit every time you up vote the person
who posted that post is like yeah I got
an up vote so you're actually being like
you're bringing a lot of like good vibes
let's say to your LinkedIn community
when you're engaging in other people's
content so just kind of think of it from
that perspective engage because it's
good to be top of mind engage because it
makes people feel good engage because
you can learn something from the things
that you post and share and comment on
and just try and be positive and and
bring you know good intent and helpful
information to people in your network
and if you do that on a consistent basis
people will take notice and honestly
like if you have any any sort of
charisma that shows up well on video
right now LinkedIn video is the best
organic reach you can get that will
change eventually as advertisers move in
and
same with like Instagram stuff like
Instagram is no longer as organically
successful you kind of have to pay to
play now but LinkedIn if you want to
create some videos just talking about
your work talking about projects talking
about data science things like that I
don't know you're going to get in front
of a lot of eyeballs and that's good for
your search because then people might
comment and then you can be like hey
it's you look like you're doing an
interesting job you want to get coffee
that might lead to a role for you
someday who knows thank you so much for
your question
roy wang has a question how can a UX
designer better use LinkedIn to find
internships so I'm going to reiterate
what we talked about earlier use the
search functionality to network with
people who are currently UX designers
reach out to them ask them what they
love about their work what they're
struggling with what they're excited
about what they need help with and
they'll say a bunch of stuff and then if
you want an internship say you know I
have some time in my schedule it sounds
like you're struggling with X Y & Z very
simple tasks I could help out a couple
hours a week as an intern if that's
something you're interested in I'll even
do it for free because I'm just looking
to get some experience and build my
resume would that be something you're
interested in that's how you turn a
networking interaction into a job or an
internship you don't go up to them and
immediately say give me a job you go up
to them and you learn about them you
learn about their struggles you learn
about what they're trying to accomplish
well you know what what projects are
coming down the pipeline that you're
super excited about building and you
know what are some of the things that
might prevent you from accomplishing
that if you get an answer to that
question you can go home and say I could
help in a certain way so let's say from
a marketing standpoint talking to
someone and saying you know oh cool you
have a new product coming out you know
it sounds really exciting how are you
doing your social media and they'll be
like you actually we don't have a social
media plan right now oh well I'm looking
to get some social media experience
would you mind if I intern for you a
couple hours a week nope you wouldn't
have to pay me I'll just do it I'll get
social media experience you'll get some
free posts on your Instagram or whatever
it might be and you know value going
both ways and if you have more
experience you charge a consulting fee
or a contract fee and and that's how you
sort of build up to a full time job if
you're trying to get in as an intern at
this point so great question Roy thanks
for sharing
Fernando is it recommended to discourage
is a sorry is it recommended or
discouraged to use easy apply on
LinkedIn for a job application
additionally should I use the in mail
option on LinkedIn to send a job
application directly to the job poster
so many great points in this question
all right let's try and break it down is
it recommended or discouraged to use
easy apply on LinkedIn for a job
application
anytime something says easy or will do
it for you or come here and we'll solve
your problems I always have a strong
negative reaction because the truth of
the matter is there is no such thing as
an easy job search especially when
you're trying to break into a field or
change careers or something like that I
like to think of the easy apply as a
passive job search so if you already
have a job and you're just browsing and
you don't want to put a ton of effort in
because you're actually kind of happy
where you're at but hey this looks
interesting
easy apply it's fine I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna you know hate on that but if
you are gunning for a job right now if
you have like four months left till you
are broke or something along those lines
I would not be easy applying to anything
I would be customizing my cover letter
trying to customize my resume as much as
possible reaching out and networking
with people
easy apply is like out of sight out of
mind if you are actively job searching
you need to be actively engaged so I
would discourage easy apply for people
who need a job who are trying to make a
change who have a a very like focused
goal that they need to accomplish the
next thing you ask is should I use the
in mail option on LinkedIn to send a job
application directly to the job poster
this is a great question too I just
applied for a job it told me who the
person is can I use in mail attachment
may say I just applied you can but
here's the thing you always have to look
at it from the other person's
perspective if and here's how those
emails typically look from what I've
seen someone says job opening or
whatever your subject line is like just
applied they open your in mail and it
says hi my name is I just applied give
me a job here's my resume everything is
about you you don't talk about the
problems you solve you don't talk about
the company and how you want to
contribute to their goals and their
vision of the future you you're just
asking for a job in the morning or
asking for a job the less people want to
give you a job because it sounds very
selfish but the more you're talking
about the value you can provide them the
the more you talk about how much you
care about their goals and what they
want the more receptive people are to
talking to you so if you send your
resume in an InMail the chances of you
getting a positive response are not
super high you probably won't get
negative responses you probably just get
no response what I think is a much
better way to do it is to say all right
that person that person is the is the
main contact maybe instead of re sending
my resume which they already have and
they're gonna put through the system
anyway
reach out and just say hey I saw you or
the hiring manager looks like you have
some really interesting things going on
and I'm really excited to you know
continue the conversation learn about
the company and see if there's any value
I can bring to the team thank you so
much for your consideration I hope
you're having a wonderful day so now
you're following up on your application
which is a good thing but you're doing
it in a way that's more about them and
how much you care about them then about
what they can do for you and if they see
that then they'll go look you up in the
application system and potentially bring
you in for a role so I would definitely
err on the side of making it more about
them and then when it comes to using in
mail and things like that
I typically discourage connecting with
someone on LinkedIn as your
thing because typically if they don't
know who you are they'll only really do
one thing for you so if they've hit
connect accept connection then the
chances of getting a coffee with them go
down but you can use in mail to get in
touch with them without connecting with
them then you can in your in mail say it
looks like you're doing some interesting
things we'd love to grab coffee and
learn more about you know what you're
working on grab coffee with them and
then after the coffee connect with them
on LinkedIn because then they're like oh
I know this person I want them in my
network that's something you can do
within mail if you have the option of in
mail but you can also do it by looking
up their emails somewhere else you can
use find that email you can use a number
of different like clear bit I think is
another one to find someone's email and
and just reach out to them and say while
I was researching this industry your
profile came up looks like you're doing
some great work would you be open to
coffee I'd love to learn more about what
you're doing and what you're working on
and see and and just see if there's any
thing I don't know I'm kind of trailing
off at the end there but like see if I
can bring value basically and so you
have those conversations and then you
connect and then you can start a
dialogue over time so you can use I
would recommend using in mail but I
would recommend using it in a slightly
different way than just sending your
resume a second time
[Music]
our next question is from beta and it's
a hard one this is uh this is a great
question I appreciate you for sharing
I'll share as much information as I can
as I know of around this topic but there
will be more research that that you'll
need to go do after after we talk here
but do you think it's possible to
completely change your career in your
early 40s is that too late to learn how
to code with the aim of becoming a
machine engineer my initial answer here
is it's not too late I don't believe
that 40 is is so far beyond like the
ability to learn something new and
change your career if it's something you
really want to do now to do that you're
gonna have to do the same thing that
someone who's 20 would have to do they
would have to start from the beginning
and learn it and get an internship and
move up if this is something they've
never done before so you know I was
talking to a 27 year old who was moving
from being a chef to being or sorry from
being a pianist to being a coder well
they're being paid this much as a
pianist and they're gonna be paid this
much as a coder because they're you know
starting again you might need to take
that into consideration looking at your
life circumstances you know family
commitments other things mortgages
there's all sorts of stuff that maybe a
23 year old wouldn't have to deal with
or wouldn't have to consider they can
take bigger risks but I don't think that
it's not worth trying I think that you
know 40 in in the world right now you
know you've got if 65 is the is the
retirement age you've got a lot of years
still ahead of you and most people
aren't retiring at 65 so you know what
do you want to do for the next 30 years
of your career I think in the next 30
years you can learn machine engineering
you learn how to become a machine
engineer and pursue it you got a long
ass went oops sorry sorr you got a long
window to to get there and so I would
encourage you to do it if it's something
that you actually have like a strong
interest in and your
look the only reason I would say don't
do it is if you're like I want to make
this change because I heard in the news
that you know people who are you know in
this field make a lot of money the
people that I see making decisions based
off that have low motivation and don't
get as far but if you actually are
really interested in the topic and in
the education and and you really want to
learn it you're learning it on your own
already go for it I don't see why not
but that's just my recommendation there
is some ageism in the tech world so you
want to do some research on that and
just see like you know are there
organizations that that you know are
supportive are there companies that are
more open to people of different ages I
know it's kind of a it's kind of a weird
place right now with ageism I know
there's a lot of conversations going on
and I'm by no means an expert so you
definitely want to do a little bit of
research on that but I don't know I'm
much more of a fan of of going out and
learning new things and try new things
and making a change if that's what's
right for you so I encourage it
all right this is gonna be I'm going to
see how many questions we can get in
five minutes here but I'm gonna jump to
dunya you asked should we explain a
career change in our LinkedIn profile
this is a really interesting question
I've never come across someone who is
explaining a career change in their
profile however if you were to explain a
career change I would ask where in the
profile are you thinking of doing it are
you doing it in the description of a job
or are you doing it in your summary I
think it is interesting to maybe call
attention to a diverse career path and
maybe that's a better way to look at it
you're looking at it as a career change
as a bit is maybe a negative thing and I
have to explain it to people whereas I
don't typically look at it that way I
look at a career change as an evolution
in your interests so let's say you know
you go back to the my the the person I
was working with who was a pianist right
so they were really interested in music
growing up and they were really good at
the piano and they built a career around
playing the piano then they reached like
the top of where they could get as a
piano player and they said I'm trying to
look out for my future I'm gonna go
learn programming I'm gonna learn
programming because it's very similar to
learning music it's a language it's like
binary kinda you know all these
different things that are there's a lot
of similarities between music and
encoding it's creative but it's also
like math based and so what they said
was this was the next evolution and so
I'm someone who brings or for them it
was like I'm someone who is bringing my
background in music in flow and math and
and all those different things and
languages and applying it in this new
field so I've evolved from applying it
to make music to applying the same
skillset to making websites and mobile
apps and things like that and so they
evolved so I would take a look at your
career change what did you what are you
coming from and what are you moving
towards and then try and find you know a
relational aspect that flows through
those two things
you know what was it about your last job
that set you up for this job and then
talk about it as an evolution the way I
like to talk about it so I used to be in
marketing now I'm in career development
and actually I'm doing a bit of both
right so I say as a mark I merge a
background in behavioral marketing with
an interest in career development to
help people be seen during the during
their job search and land new roles so
that's taking my past merging it with my
my future and showing the outcome so if
you could do that I think you're gonna
be in a really good place all right I'm
gonna end with one more question from
Raja what is the best way to get into
Google and Amazon as a data scientist
after finishing my masters at university
this is a great question because I get
this all the time and I'm gonna lump
this in with well I'm just gonna give
you my opinion on it when whenever
someone comes to me and says I want to
work whenever someone comes to me says I
want to work at Google or Amazon I ask
why and typically the answer is because
it's Google or Amazon duh and I'm like
that's not a good enough reason like
there are millions and millions of
people who want to work at Google and
Amazon because they're the biggest names
in the world what is gonna make you
different why did why does Google or
Amazon want you and the truth of the
matter is if you're only wanting to work
at Google and Amazon because it's a big
name that will look good on your resume
it's gonna be a hard conversation to
have to convince them to hire you
because that's what everyone wants so
you need to get a little bit deeper I
worked with someone who wanted to work
at Amazon because of you know voice
search and and they want to work at
Google because of Google home so of
Alexa and Google home I don't want to
say it's China and so what you need to
do is say alright I've that guy had a
background in linguistics was really
interested in programming wanted to
combine the two in
to work on the future of voice search so
these companies clearly make sense they
didn't just want to work at Amazon
generally they wanted to work at a
specific thing in Amazon and if they
couldn't get that they'd work at the
hundred other companies that are working
on that kind of technology Siri Google
home and a million other things voice in
your car voice in your grocery store all
the different things that are out there
so instead of focusing just on big names
focus on why you want to work at those
big names what are the technologies that
you're most interested in and then open
up your search try and find other
companies because you might not get to
Google right away but maybe you can get
into Google's partners and that will
lead to Google in five years take a
bigger view of it and find your way in
alright thank you so much for your
questions today this has been an awesome
conversation tons and tons of questions
that we didn't get to so I I apologize
for that but it's been absolutely
wonderful hearing everything it's on
your mind seeing your growth seeing
where you're taking things in your
search thank you so much for joining ask
a career coach today in the comments
please fill out or we're gonna share a
link for the next ask a career coach so
sign up today and share it with anyone
else that you know who is searching for
a job right now we really want to bring
in as many ideas into these
conversations and try and help you as
much as we can to improve your search
reduce your anxiety and get where you
want to be in your career so thank you
again for joining us and I hope you have
a wonderful rest of the day